there's a lot of great things in the
documentary back and forth but there's
uh there's one moment the very end of
the documentary I thought it was over
I'm just about to turn it off when
actually there's a snippet of you Dave
saying uh I if I thought the Foo
Fighters was ever going to be this big
I'd have come up with a better name for
the band are you not impressed with the
name Foo Fighter you know I'm really
happy with what's happened over the last
16 years we're really lucky and I love
being in this band but honestly Foo
Fighters is like the stupidest band name
it's a horrible name what's with the
language tonight I don't know it's a
terror I mean the reason why I called it
Foo Fighters was because the first thing
that I recorded uh was I did it by
myself and I played all the instruments
I played drums and guitar and bass and
sang and I made this cassette but I
didn't want people to know it was me
because I didn't want people to think
like oh that guy from Nirvana is trying
to start another band so I just called
it
Foo Fighters because it sounded like a
group of people right yeah and I had
read it in a UFO book or something like
that and um but it stuck and it stayed
all this time and I just can't believe
if I knew that we were we would be here
on your show 16 years later you know
you've made it when you're here
[Applause]
someday Conan's gonna be on TBS and I'll
be there uh
did you now okay well well Taylor what
do you think of the band name see I
thought it was really cool you liked it
yeah so I must be really a [ __ ] but
so are there band names that you like
what are they what do you guys think of
the quintessential cool band names like
Rush Queen when I was a kid Queen The
Ramones Ramones is a great man name
sticks
Air Supply
[Applause]
The Josie and the Pussycats
thank you
know what's interesting when I one of
the things I did not appreciate uh it's
such a good documentary about the
struggle of a band to to form what I did
not appreciate is how many lineup
changes that you guys have have been
through uh Taylor you were the second
second drummer uh for Foo Fighters and
what happens is you make the point the
documentary that that a lot of every
rock band goes through a lot of lineup
changes or most of them do but it
usually happens before they're famous
yeah
I mean you know the way we function is
really not that different than any
garage band that lives in your
neighborhood we're we're normal people
we're friends and we get together and we
write songs on our own and we recorded
this album in our garage and so you know
we're just we're just kids right playing
music We Do It for the same reason we
did
we were doing it back then and I think
that
you know when you when you go through
that kind of stuff like Johnny went to
college
and this guy quit because his parents
were Mormon and didn't want him in the
Band anymore and we like a band like us
we went through the same thing uh but we
had to do the whole thing we had to do
it in public in front of everybody right
so well you may uh you made the point in
the job actors yes you made the point in
the documentary that uh Nirvana went
through this you were the I didn't
realize you were the fifth drummer I was
the fifth drummer of Nirvana they had a
lot of drummers they were from Aberdeen
Washington and so but they're they're
early drummers one of their early the
people that were in Nirvana before I
joined were just bananas they were all
just crazy like the first one of them
drove a truck through like a supermarket
window once with the mayor's daughter in
the truck you know and then like that
was his audition
there was there like a 50 year old dude
like with a mustache that was a pavement
and but then this other guy the first
time I met their first drummer we were
at a laundromat and he comes in he goes
hey man and he hands me some quarters
and he goes I'm going to get in this
dryer put those quarters in once you
close the door okay
and that was that's what you gotta do to
be a Nirvana